the globish parsonage in saxony-anhalt
has seen better days the stove is being
stoked to warm up the place for the
senior group who are about to arrive
they meet here every Wednesday but not
for much longer
Pastor Jurgen Hoffmann has to give up
the house because there's no one left to
save to the upkeep of the old building
globish all the tenants are moving out
the windows and roof are all new but the
house doesn't have central heating that
makes it very difficult to find new
tenants so we decided to sell the house
[Music]
this isn't the first parsonage Hoffman
has closed at least this time there's
another place to live lined up for him
he just hopes the small community holds
together he's relying on God's help for
that this is something God does quite
often he fulfills the desires we have
deep in our hearts but fewer and fewer
parishioners are attending church
services and devotions the culinary
delights of gooseberry and cheesecake
are a tried-and-true means for the
pastor to disseminate Luther's message
so that was globe acknow we're going to
the neighboring village rotten pork the
mother group meets there at 3:30
we'll make that easy enough and then
we'll hit the road again it's a
full-time job split between senior
citizens and the mother's group seven
days a week the villages that belonged
to the Zonk petra parish are located
within a thirty kilometer radius only
one in ten people here is still a member
of the protestant church
despite its close proximity to Vinton
burg the cradle of the Reformation is it
now a God forsaken region when you say
godforsaken I'd say God forgotten at
least in a lot of areas east Germany
wasn't particularly successful
especially not economically but sadly it
succeeded at one thing very well
combating religion we're still feeling
the effects of that
[Music]
the mother circle in Battenberg is
actually more of a grandmother circle
daughters and granddaughters are few and
far between many young women leave the
region and find work elsewhere you don't
really see them in church anymore once
they have their coming-of-age party or
confirmation you rarely see them after
that said but that's how it is 500 years
after the Reformation began in Vinton
burg there's not much evidence in the
region of the people's church they're
just not interested maintaining contact
to the next generation is crucial
pastor Hoffman is on the board of the
YMCA in Vinton burg the Young Men's
Christian Association at least the
Reformation anniversary celebrations
gave the organization of boost a summer
project has become a lasting youth club
we hope the kids will ask us why we are
doing this and that our staff members
can say I'm doing this because I believe
in God and I have a relationship with
Jesus and then they can talk about what
that means get the conversation started
the pastor doesn't see himself as a
prayer leader for a silent community but
rather as a guide for those exploring
their faith very much in the spirit of
Martin Luther we always had a church for
all people in Germany that meant that
everyone belonged to the church
community now we need a new paradigm the
church must be there for the people even
those who aren't currently members
because Sunday after Sunday he contends
with a half-empty Church Pastor Hoffman
fights for every surface attendee every
four weeks a youth band plays which
brings a few more people than usual into
church but they should do more than just
sit back and listen I ask you all now to
please close your eyes try to create a
picture of what I am reading in your
mind
God's sitting on the throne and being
glorified holy holy holy Lord God
Almighty Lord of power and might faith
is God's work in us according to the
teachings of Martin Luther five hundred
years on pastor Hoffman is struggling to
find people still willing to hear the
Reformers message
[Music]